عندما يفرد جناحيه يكشف تفاصيل ارث شعبي
اصيل يمتد لاكثر من 2500 عام والاسطوره
تقول انه كان مرتبطا بالهه الشمس انه
كندور الانديز العملاق اضخم طائر في
العالم تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده
من عالم غريب
كندور الانديز هو احد طيور قاره امريكا
الجنوبيه الذي ينتمي لفصيله نسور العالم
الجديد وهو اكبر طائر جارح في العالم
ويعيش لنحو 70 عاما السكان الاصليون في
جبال الانديز يقدسونه لدرجه ان اسطورتهم
تقول ان هذا الطائر المخيفه كان حاكم
العالم العلوي بل ان السكان الاصليين ايضا
اعتقدوا ان عين الكوندور كانت عينا لهم
لرؤيه الكون الواسع
بالنسبه للسكان الاصليين في جبال الانديز
الجنوبيه على وجه الخصوص يلعب الكوندور
دورا مهما للغايه في رؤيتهم الكونيه انه
رسول الشمس
وهو جزء كبير من عالمهم الاسطوري ايضا
يعيش كوندور الانديز على السواحل المجاوره
في غرب المحيط الهادئ وامريكا الجنوبيه
وفي جبال الانديز ولانه يرمز للقوه والصحه
في الكثير من ثقافات السكان الاصليين هناك
اعتقدوا ان عظامه واعضاءه الحيويه تمتلك
خصائص طبيه فكثرت حالات صيده الى ان اصبح
مهددا بالانقراض
تواجه طيور الكندور وضعا معقدا انها تعيش
في منطقه تمتد من اقصى الشمال من جبال
الانديز في كولومبيا الى اقصى الجنوب في
كولومبيا وفنزويلا والاكوادور وتتعرض لخطر
الانقراض حتى انها انقرضت عمليا في
فنزويلا
المسافه بين جناحي كوندور الانديز تزيد
على ثلاثه امتار لذا يعتبر اكبر طائر جارح
قادر على الطيران في العالم وقوته الجسديه
تمكنه من اكل الجيف الكبيره كالغزلان او
الماشيه ويتمتع ايضا بذكاء خارق فهو يعي
جيدا ان وزنه يصل لخمسه عشر كيلو جراما
احيانا لذلك يفضل العيش والطيران في
المناطق ذات الاجواء العاصفه والرياح
العاتيه لان الرياح تساعد في حمل وزنه
الثقيل فلا يبذل جهدا كبيرا في الطيران
تلك الصفات المميزه دفعت الى اعتبار كندور
الانديز رمزا وطريا في بعض الدول التي
يعيش فيها كابوليفيا وتشيلي وكولومبيا
والاكوادور وطبعت صوره على بعض العملات
النقديه وطوابع البريد في الارجنتين وبيرو
وفنزويلا لذا فان مساله انقراده قد تترك
اثرا كبيرا في نفوس سكان تلك الدول
[موسيقى]